hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra's never seen and
welcome to mama today I am watching
Goodfellas for the first time I will be
tackling Godfather 1 Godfather 2 and
Scarface as well this month and I'm
really excited / worried that I'll think
they're a little boring
Godfather wanted to I really have been
ignoring because I'm an idiot when it
comes to reviewing films I know this you
all certainly know it as I've seen in
the comments section I make mistakes
when I'm reacting to these movies and I
say things that are dumb to film fans
and so to tackle something so well-known
so just like unanimously loved and just
awards and renowned and amazing and
great I get a little antsy a little
nervous that I'm going to mistakes so
today I'm starting with Goodfellas and I
really hope that I like it almost more I
hope that you like it well I know about
will see it let's do it
[Music]
as far back as I can remember I've
always wanted to be a gangster
I need you to say that for the camera
bud
sure yeah no it was an amazing movie
I met idiot for not having seen it sure
fine alright there's the video see you
next week bye
you see there's tape on my fingers
because these rings are gigantic but I
had to be a mob wife so I had to have
big gems you know it's difficult it's
it's hard being a gangster what is that
term it isn't easy being sleazy what
damn it feels good to be a gangster
that's what I'm thinking this is a
really long movie and I didn't write
that many notes on it when a movie is
ridiculous and bad like battleship that
I recently did I write pages and pages
and pages and pages of notes because I
hate it
technics difficult to get there so that
really just entertains me as they're
watching this abysmal movie this though
I didn't write down like beat by beat
what was happening and I just wrote down
things that really stood out to me so
this is gonna be less of a me going
through and telling you what happens in
a movie that you clearly know what
happens already with four by and more of
me just genuinely telling you what I
thought about this movie good bad good
fella's
Goodfellas more like great fellas okay
moving on first of all I don't know if
it's from my vanilla upbringing or what
but I really enjoy when movies have a
ton of violence and a ton of bad
language it just tickles me to my core
and this one certainly did and it kept
me on my toes it really didn't bore me
like I thought it was going to I have
been avoiding watching this movie for
long diamonds and I put it in
reluctantly and I sat down I was like oh
my god okay maybe I'll pause it in the
middle watch the rest tomorrow and from
the get-go it got me it was so good so
entertaining I love how you grow with
the character and you grow with him
obviously with him like growing an age
but you also grow with the music of a
style the music changes with the
different eras that we're in you're
going through like time like it starts
in the 50s right 1955 and 63 then 80 and
you you go through all these different
time periods different music within
those time periods and its really well
paced she the point where Lee at the end
he's addicted to drugs and the the shots
are way more chaotic and crazy and
shoppi and the music isn't like this
long drawn-out beautiful the same with
the shots long drawn-out beautiful it's
more just like bam bam bam hear you
thank you ma'am kind of do you I'll take
this the end editing is like Tamra's
never seen any chaotic and crazy
jazzy nonsensical but great the acting
was amazing the character development
Caylor obviously it's based on a true
story and I watched a history buffs
video on this right after watching the
movie and apparently most of it is
really really accurate much different
than when I saw Cool Runnings
and it was thoroughly bitchin I love
Henry but I think my favorite character
has to be Karen it's really cool she
goes through the different levels of
being in a mob family the same way that
Henry really does - he has moments of
doubt and moments of kind of adjusting
to things and learning as he goes along
and same with her she's really
whenever more maybe not innocent
characters but she's like a vessel into
the sweeter side of some of these other
characters she challenges Henry she
brings up a lot of plot points where he
has mistresses and where she does if you
loved and she's gonna kill him and like
lots of different things but just make
her really interesting and like
different than like the group of
mobsters that we see a lot of who are
also just really really well done and
not boring at all I don't know why I
thought that mob movies were gonna be so
boring though I do hear that this is the
more exciting version of Godfather I
don't know if that's accurate think that
they're very differently paced but I'm a
little nervous to see godmother okay
moving on Joe Pesci plays Tommy DeVito
they kept saying Tommy DeVito in the
movie and I was like oh yeah cool Danny
DeVito mixing up Joe Pesci and Danny
DeVito so I hated his character he was
reckless he ruins things when he was
killed I felt no remorse like what about
me is so funny you said that I oh you
didn't say that it was funny okay hmm
I hope they make it look awesome just
like such a blast you're family you're
having a wealthy time everyone else is
like blue-collar working you know Henry
had seven brothers and sisters grew up
with like an immigrant family and all he
wants to do is be a gangster and he did
it he realized his dreams he made them
happen also I now know what this meme is
from
I'm in on the joke nailed it I wrote I
love the girlfriend then the wife
character carriage you awesome sassy
gorgeous sweet not supermodel tough I
love her narrative throughout I will say
though that Karen is such a name such a
like come on shut up Karen stop putting
potato salad in that soup Karen you've
never seen Goodfellas Karen I mean the
best part about being a gangster in this
movie is just like the endless funds
drugs beautiful women beautiful men
power power over the law and probably
the worst part about being a gangster is
the looming possibility of always maybe
getting punched to death so the jail
scene was really interesting where
they're eating all this nice food and
really all they talked about was food
and Karen is smuggling in drugs to him
come on Karen the third act is him
addicted to drugs and he goes to jail
for coke and you see the dirtier side
where the drugs are involved versus at
the front end it wasn't about drugs as
much and it was a lot better of an
operation he gets out on bail and then
he keep rats on all of his friends out
and goes to witness protection that
sucks so bad for all of his friends but
I'm like alright cool
you got your whole family it's cool now
and like he's out in like suburban
America somewhere and kind of hates it
and he's just living in a normal life
and a normal he just that's not who he
is he's grown up his entire life being
this one thing and then to go so I
wonder how that is I would love to now
watch the interviews with the actual
Henry Hill and read the book that he
wrote I think it's also so interesting
and so much more interesting that they
kept it so close to the source material
I also loved in true story movies where
they have the screen of text at the end
make sure you like a picture that it's
tamra chambers went on to do nothing
with her Saturday afternoon those kind
of things love him it was great it kept
my attention the whole time and that's
really all I want from a movie just keep
my attention just cut out the boring bit
pace to go add somewhere else the bit I
always thought I would hate mom movies
but I don't think I've ever actually sat
through an entire one it's ridiculous
saw that one with Johnny Depp a few
years back I hated that I'm excited for
Godfather I'm excited to finally cross
this bridge that this has always been on
my list of Tamara's never seen movies
that I need to see and I'm really
excited to do it
I'm really excited to come at it
positively now that I saw this I'm so
into it I'm really just I'm ready I'm
excited and I'm ready and I'm let's do
it let's fit limit let's sip it damn
feels good to be a gangster I give this
movie 9 hair flips out of 10 hair flips
what thank you for watching I will see
you all next week
it's far back as I can remember I've
always wanted to be a gangster and look
at me now gangster in it at selling
cameras stealing wet food smuggling
entry
[Music]
[Applause]
you